Well let's review a little
bit everything that
we've covered so far.
So what was the Maclaurin
Series representation
of e to the x?
And once again, you'll have to
take my word for it, that the
Maclaurin Series representation
really does equal, when you
take the infinite series, it
really does equal e to the x.
I mentioned in a previous
video that I was thinking
about the proof.
And I finally gave up because I
couldn't think of the proof.
And then I looked it up and I
realized why I couldn't think
of the proof, it's
quite involved.
But I will do it eventually.
Probably after I cover a lot of
other things just because it's
not something that you really
have to know to succeed well in
calculus, or appreciate
what we're about to do.
But I will do it.
It'll probably take
five or six minutes.
Anyway back to where we were.
So the Maclaurin Series
repetition of e to the x, and
it actually does equal e to the
x, is 1 plus x, plus x squared
over 2 factorial, plus x to the
third over 3 factorial.
I'm going to do a bunch of
terms and you'll see why.
And x to the fourth over 4
factorial, plus x to the fifth,
over 5 factorial, plus x to the
sixth, over 6 factorial, plus
x to the seventh over 7
factorial, plus x to the
eighth over 8 factorial.
And it just keeps going on
and on to infinity, right?
Only when we take the infinite
series does it exactly
equal e to the x.
Fair enough.
Well what was the Maclaurin
Series representation
of cosine of x?
Well that equaled -- and I'm
going to space them out in a
certain way, and I think you'll
see why -- it equalled 1 plus x
squared over -- oh no, sorry, 1
minus, this is a minus sign,
let me erase that because I
want to make this as
neat as possible.
Equal to 1 minus x squared over
2 factorial, right, we learned
that two videos ago, plus x
to the fourth over for 4
factorial, minus x to the
sixth over 6 factorial.
I think you might already know
know where I'm going with this.
Plus x to the eighth over 8
factorial, and it just kept
going, the next digit would
be a minus out here.
And it goes to infinity, right?
For that pattern, you
know the pattern.
And what is sine of x?
What's the Maclaurin Series
representation for sine of x?
Well, sine of x, it equals x
minus x to the third over 3
factorial, plus x to the fifth
over 5 factorial, minus x to
the seventh over 7 factorial,
and it just keeps going.
You'd have an x to
the ninth out here.
But it goes on for
infinity, right?
These all go on for infinity,
but you know the pattern.
So let's just pause here
because this is, I think if you
understand what's going on, one
of the few things in life that
will truly give you chills.
It'll truly make you believe
that there is a order to the
universe that we as
human beings can only
catch a glimpse of.
We have limited minds.
But we are on the verge, we're
scraping the surface, but
there's something amazing here.
Cosine of x and sine of x.
Each of their Maclaurin Series
representations, or if you were
essentially to write them as
polynomials, each of them looks
like it's almost like part
of e to the x, right?
It's almost every other digit.
And they would be the
same except for a
couple of sign changes.
Let me make that clear.
So what if I were to define
the function cosine
of x plus sine of x?
What would that equal?
Or what would it's Maclaurin
Series representation
of that be?
Well, and then we know
that it's also equal.
But it's essentially
adding these two rows.
So it would be 1 plus x, minus
squared over 2 factorial,
minus x to the third over 3
factorial, plus x to the fourth
over 4 factorial, plus x to the
fifth over 5 factorial, minus x
to the sixth over 6 factorial,
minus x to the seventh over 7
factorial, plus x to the
eight over 8 factorial.
And it just keeps going, right?
The next one would be a plus,
it goes on to infinity.
Now I think it should be clear
to you that something, that the
goose bumps should be
emerging on your arm.
Because look at this,
and look at e to the x.
What's the difference?
Well, just a couple of negative
signs here and there.
Let me do it in a
slightly brighter color.
So the only difference between
this function and this function
are these negative signs.
And I've seen this before, I've
learned this before, people for
hundreds of years
have known this.
But I'll tell you something.
No one, even though they can
prove it mathematically, no one
really understands why this is.
Why we take these trigonometric
functions that appear, you
know, when we take the ratios
of the sides of a right
triangle, or the unit circle
definition, and you know it's
useful for, you know, triangle
measure, that's trigonometry.
That's where we came up with
this cosine and sine functions.
And it's related to the
circle and all the rest.
That when you add these two
fundamental functions together
from trigonometry, right?
Because tangent is really
just the ratio of
the sine to cosine.
So these are really what
trigonometry, this is the
basis of trigonometry.
When you add their polynomial
representations together, it's
almost exactly, except for
these negative signs, the
polynomial representation
of e to the x.
And the number e, and first
of all, this is an exponent,
these are no exponents here.
And e is just completely
unrelated, or at least one
would think from trigonometry.
Right, e is, we got e from
compound interest, you'll
see that it's related to
exponential growth, exponential
decay, when you have continuous
exponential growth and decay,
continuous compound interest.
If this number that is in a
completely unrelated field of,
not just mathematics, but
really the universe, right?
Continuous interest vs.
the ratios of the sides
of right triangles.
So this should already be
getting you thinking.
But what would be even more
amazing is if we could somehow
work with these to make them
a little bit more equal.
Well, the only thing that's
different are these
negative signs, right?
So do we know anything else
in mathematics, in our
mathematical tool kit,
that has this pattern?
Where it goes positive
positive, negative negative,
positive positive,
negative negative?
It has this essentially
the cycle of four.
Well you might be thinking, and
this will even give you larger
goose bumps, or make your
current ones bigger, the number
i, or the imaginary unit i.
So what are the powers of i?
This is a little review.
If this is completely
unfamiliar to you, you should
re-watch the imaginary
numbers video.
So what are the powers of i?
Well i to the zero is 1, i to
the first is i, i squared is
negative 1, i to the third
power, that's negative 1
times i, so it's negative i.
i to the fourth power is i
times negative i, so the
i's become negative 1 and
then you have a negative
there, so it becomes 1.
And the pattern repeats itself.
i to the fifth is i, i to
the sixth is negative 1.
We learned this before,
but it's just a review.
i to the seventh is negative
i, i to the eighth
then becomes 1 again.
So there you have it,
this is amazing.
i has that property where the
second two in the cycle of
four are negative, right?
We have a negative number here.
This is not necessarily a
negative number, it's a
negative imaginary number, but
we have that negative sign, so
it looks pretty similar, right?
Then we have two positives,
then we have a negative
and a negative.
And something else is
interesting going on here.
Wherever we see the imaginary
number, whenever we see an i
or a negative i, which terms
do they correspond to?
Well they correspond to the
terms of sine of x, right?
It corresponds to that term,
negative i corresponds
to that term.
i corresponds to that term,
negative i corresponds
to that term.
So we have something, it
seems a little bit even
more of a pattern.
But anyway, I just realized I
only have -- I have to say I'm
normally pretty smooth in these
videos, but when I start
talking about what I'm talking
about right now, my brain
starts to go in circles.
Because this is, I've actually
even heard, you know, what
we're what we're about to touch
on, as proof of the
existence of God.
And really, that's not that
much of an exaggeration.
It is definitely proof of the
existence of some hidden order
of the universe that we can
only catch a glimpse of.
And maybe you can
call that God.
But anyway, I don't want to get
metaphysical on you, but I will
see you in the next video.